only if I post like the wrong selfie and
I'm like that other selfie was so much
better than that selfie but other than
that you know I don't really write
anything well Kylie Jenner might regret
this according to a rod the 21 year old
was being pretty vocal at this year's
Met Gala about just how rich she really
is a rod makes a claim in the new issue
of Sports Illustrated revealing he
shared a table with Kendall and Kylie
inside the star-studded affair
we're so not gonna be a part of this
night he said quote Kylie was talking
about Instagram and her lipstick and how
rich she is I'm Kylie Jenner and I am
the founder of Kylie cosmetics Kylie is
really rich last year Forbes dubbed her
the youngest self-made billionaire all
because of those lipsticks and her Kylie
cosmetics line I put so much love into
everything that I make and I make sure
everything is perfect and something I
would personally use starting a company
on my own and it being so big from the
beginning there's not a lot of room for
mistakes but this isn't the first time
Kylie's been called out for her antics
even sister Kourt did it on their show
earlier this month but Kim and Mama Kris
have always had Kylie's back she works
really hard she made her own money for
over a decade she put it in the bay she
saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
it's not like that was handed to her she
figured that all out I mean we all have
[Applause]
[Music]